europe wants to be the first climate  neutral continent in the world  even though the finish line is 30 years  away  the race starts now the 2020s is the  make or break decade and that's why  europe has committed to reduce our  emissions  by at least 55 by 2030  compared to 1990 levels  [Music]  we must guide our societies to a cleaner  and healthier future  this transition will affect our daily  lives from the cars we drive from the  houses we live in from the jobs we will  have in the future  i'm confident that we can make it if we  do two things  if we set ourselves a sound direction  and stand together as a continent in  mastering the challenge  we are building a model for a clean  economy  that is also a prosperous economy and  both is doable